[Music]
tonight tonight
it all began tonight
[Music]
what do you do
all day i had the feeling a miracle
would happen
i know now i was right
for here you are
and what was just a world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the world is full of life
[Music]
this is my first time in new york city
i want to be happy here i want to make a
life at home
[Music]
are you ready
tonight is about family
the first gringo boy who smiles at you
i never seen you before
you're not puerto rican
is that okay
do you want to start world war iii
[Applause]
you know i wake up to everything i know
either getting sold or wrecked or being
taken over by people that i don't like
you keep away from him as long as you're
in my house
i'm a grown up now bernardo i'm gonna
think for myself
tony
we need you if we're going to war
who are you
wonderful
if you go with him
no one will ever forgive you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
life matters
even more than love
know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you